monsieur le premier ministre un
référendum le jour des élections
européennes
les pauvres élections européennes
n'avaient rien demandé et un référendum
pour répondre à des manifestants d'hier
et d'aujourd'hui qui disent trop
d'impôts trop de taxes passé pouvoir
d'achat une dépense publique à revoir
trop de contraintes réglementaires et on
envisage un référendum qui dit on va
parler du parlement
trop de députés trop de sénateurs trop
de mandat ce qui n'est pas exactement on
peut pas le dire une réponse sociale
économique par rapport aux demandes de
la population
alors monsieur le premier ministre comme
je sais que vous êtes un homme de raison
est ce que tous ces fakes news doivent
être démentie est ce que c'est une vraie
piste du gouvernement vers quoi va-t-on
pour sortir du grand débat pour vous
répondre
la parole et madame le garde des sceaux
1 allégis madame le garde des sceaux sur
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur karoutchi depuis
quelques jours effectivement dans la
presse c'est évoqué l'idée d'un
référendum qui pourrait être organisée
au printemps pour tirer les conclusions
du grand débat national que le président
de la république a lancé la question que
vous posez donc me semble parfaitement
légitime puisque la constitution et vous
le savez prévoit dans son article 11 la
possibilité que le président de la
république puisse soumettre au
référendum un certain nombre de projets
de loi cette procédure de l'article 11 a
été utilisé huit fois depuis 1958 pour
trancher des questions importantes sur
l'avenir du pays le grand débat national
tel qu'il a été voulue par le président
de la république permette à nos
concitoyens de débattre de questions qui
sont importantes pour leur avenir
vous le savez elles ont trait à la
fiscalité elles ont trait à
l'organisation de l'état elles ont trait
à la démocratie et à la citoyenneté
elles ont trait également à la
transition écologique et au moment où
nous parlons
monsieur le sénateur il y a eu plus de
4000 réunion qui ont déjà eu lieu il y a
eu plus de 700000 contributions qui ont
déjà été déposés sur le site
je ne vois pas pourquoi vous sifflez ce
sont des chiffres réels c'est tout je
crois donc monsieur le sénateur qu'il
convient de laisser ces débats se
dérouler et vous le savez le président
de la république et le gouvernement sont
à l'écouté des français
j'ai moi même mais oui mais oui j'ai moi
même eu l'occasion de me rendre dans une
petite commune du tarn à giroussens où
les gens se respectaient est évoqué dans
le calme et la fermeté ce qu'ils
traçaient pour eux les lignes
directrices de leur avenir
je crois que une fois ce grand débat
achevée
il faudra en tirer les conséquences cela
a été clairement dit de manière précise
et concrète
il appartiendra alors au chef de l'état
et au chef du gouvernement de faire les
choix qui s'imposeront monsieur le
ministre
karoutchi je connais trop votre
engagement au gaulliste et votre
attachement aux institutions de la vème
république
roy croire que le recours à un
référendum serait pour vous critiquable
en soi mais en tout cas font qu'au
moment où nous parlons
cette question n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour monsieur karoutchi
[Musique]
je vous rassure madame la ministre je
n'ai aucune appréhension par rapport à
un référendum
je pense que le président la république
on aurait davantage mais c'est pas le
sujet là le sujet madame la ministre
monsieur le premier ministre c'est que
les français ont le droit de savoir ce
qu'est l'issue de ce débat
si vous voulez faire une réforme
constitutionnelle complète pas juste des
bricoles de l'article au 11 mai
l'utilisation de du 89 vraie réforme
près république transformée
n'hésitez pas bien parlement pour ça
vous savez la démocratie représentative
ça peut compter moi je veux bien
tous les grands débats mais j'ai entendu
le président la république dire ce qui
compte c'est quand même ceux qui ont été
élus et je vais vous dire monsieur le
premier ministre
348 sénateurs 577 députés
925 parlementaire 925 citoyens rien mais
925 parlementaires élus de manière
directe ou indirecte c'est la france
[Applaudissements]